[Music]
today we're gonna talk about how to save
80% or more by migrating your data
center into GCP my name is Jamie psy.d
I've been I'm she's a team of staff with
up teba and I've been here for about two
years and I've been focused on the
operational side of private equity for
about five years
my role is to look at the cost and
expense side of the businesses that we
get involved in typically these are
financially distressed bankrupt out of
cash no other private equity or venture
capital group wants to touch them so we
were very excited when we found Activa
it was deeply financially distressed but
the core product was really good which
made it a great fit for our type of
turnaround and I'm Keith Miller I'm the
senior vice president of Pythian
services business and we were the
services provider who was chosen to help
pop diva in this migration to GCP so
just to set the stage what is it that
Optima does when you place a phone call
or use data on your mobile phone there's
a split second where your carrier has to
determine who are you are you prepaid
postpaid or you want to my subscribers
somebody else's how am I going to get
paid it's not a particularly sexy piece
of software but it's super important if
it goes down then either the carrier has
to not let anything go through and then
all the subscribers get super grumpy or
the carrier lets things go through but
they don't get paid so uptime is is
super important in terms of what we're
bringing to the table post turnaround
for innovation we're taking this and
moving it to public cloud so telco is a
very conservative risk-averse space and
they also have to provision for peak
load so not anything particularly new
but from our perspective like well why
don't you move to somewhere where you
can pee yeah sorry you can provision for
the load that you actually need so
instead of provisioning from Mother's
Day which happens once a year and
there's multiples of what they need the
rest of the year they can scale up and
scale down so we have 100 plus customers
all over the world billions of
transactions per hour at peak here's
some of our customers one of the things
that's been interesting for me and
getting involved in this business I
follow world events a lot more closely
than I used to so if there's a coup or a
civil war or whatever I mean we have
customers in Afghanistan and Yemen in
Venezuela all over the place and I'm
much more aware of what's happening now
because it impacts our customers
immediately sure I'll just give you some
insight as to pipiens
sort of the opportunity we see on Google
cloud platform we're 20 years in
business 400 employees 350 customers
globally but it really gonna wraps up in
the love your data tagline so we've
always been good at focusing on where
the data is or where it's going and
right now we see a lot of data going to
GCP so that's what we're excited about
with the Google opportunity what do we
do
what does Pythian do on GCP there's
really two main scenarios one is the one
we're talking about today with Activa
moving bare metal or VMs from on-prem
into GCP and that can be either on to a
google cloud compute engine or on to
kubernetes so that's mostly what we're
going to talk about today the other
piece is there's a lot of optimism in
the market around what the cloud
provides as a next-generation analytics
platform so leveraging things like
bigquery on GC GCP linking your legacy
data sources to that data warehouse and
then using tools like looker tableau to
gain those insights once you've got the
real-time streaming
infrastructure in place for all of those
scenarios there's really some key things
that we talk about all the time security
how do you set up Google's security
console from day one and have people
attending to those alerts 24/7 same with
op vis stackdriver setting that up on
day one and then dealing with those 24/7
and really the order of magnitude change
or complexity that comes with cloud
is quite apparent to us so evolutionary
services once you've got a stack set up
in GCP coming in on a quarterly basis
and saying okay here's what's changed
here are the new pieces that are
available here's the ones we suggest you
drop or here's the the new ones that you
adopt so that's just sort of how Pythian
looks at the at the GCP opportunity so
what was the mess that we started with
when we got involved the company
spending about fifteen million a year on
data center which with a base of revenue
of about a hundred and fifty million and
the company wasn't a SAS company fifteen
million a year is is a lot ten
datacenters tens of thousands of square
foot of space millions a year on
electricity a hundred engineers just to
supporting the data centers this type of
location proliferation is not actually
unusual when you've got a company that's
formed by multiple success of
acquisitions each division that comes in
brings with it its own data centers its
own team and each team feels that they
have specific unique expertise that's
very hard to replace which they do have
specific expertise and it is hard to
replace but if you don't have the
discipline to consolidate then over time
eventually you get to spending fifteen
million a year and just hemorrhaging
money so our big idea for those of you
who read built to last back in the 90s
the B hag the big hairy audacious goal
was to save ninety percent going from 15
million a year to one and a half million
a year in six months we met with the
team that was there at the time we got
salt and said okay how can we shrink
this 15 million and they said well if
you know if we do this we can save 10
percent and then if we do this we can
get to 20 and if we get really
aggressive maybe we can get to 30 or 40
percent we said mmm and how long is that
going to take and they're like two maybe
three years at you know for really
disciplined we're like ah we're bleeding
here we can't wait that long so instead
what we said was let's let's move
everything possible to DCP and and then
everything that can't move to TCP let's
pick one data center and centralize
there and then optimize like crazy after
that so how do you move ten data centers
into Google
while step zero really is is pick your
cloud provider and it's worth mentioning
why we picked Google our customers that
I mentioned are telcos they're very
risk-averse and so you know they're
dealing with super sensitive personal
data name phone number location and so
they can't have data breaches so when
you walk in and you're able to point to
the huge investment that Google has made
in security that helps deescalate that
especially if you can walk in with
Google people to talk about that so that
that takes that off the table the next
reason we picked Google was the the
native products so we spent a ton on
Oracle every year and we prefer to spend
like zero so we started experimenting
with spanner and we found that we got
better performance the price was better
and we got better reliability which is a
trifecta that you just don't don't find
very often on that on that topic an
interesting part of this is this Oracle
2 spanner migration one of the things
you hear about spanners because it's the
replication anywhere idea but you've got
gdpr
compliance issue how did you deal with
spanner in that and that's setup yeah so
we that comes up with most of the
conversations we have and at least
initially we're keeping people in one
region so if you want to be in Europe
and stay within the European zones
originally we were thinking you know
Amsterdam and and England but with
brexit that gets a little more
complicated but you know let's just stay
within the region for now and then as we
get down the road a little further we're
looking at actually leveraging what's
the new name for gke on prem anthos ok
yes potentially leveraging a small
footprint on the telco side and then
cleansing the data before it goes up so
then there's not even anything that's
super sensitive in in DCP but there's
ways around it it shouldn't be a blocker
so that's step zero step one is pick
your partner and lift and shift with a
double bubble which I'll get to in a
minute and then consolidate and optimize
like crazy
so as far as the migration partner we
actually be looked at a lot of vendors
not just three but we looked at three
really seriously and we picked Pythian
because they have a deep relationship
with Google and that type of kind of
stamp of approval was meaningful for us
and then they had the best price and the
best approach and so this is worth
unpacking a little bit it's not that
they were scraping the bottom of the
barrel is that they had a world-class
team of really outstanding resources but
it was an elastic team we didn't have to
pay for the whole team the whole time so
that rolled on rolled off and then they
also invested deeply in automation so
that you know you make the use of the
team up front and then automate after
that
yeah they I mean the 17,000 virtual
machines is a big number so we called it
brave it didn't really scare us that
much if you were here last year you
might have seen us talking about the
blackberry my messenger migration that
was done around the world so very
similar sort of application footprint
not as tight a timeline as this one the
other good thing about the the sales
cycle if you will was how we were both
re outcomes focused not talking about
hours and it was very outcomes focused
and we really 50 and saw this as a great
fit for both we have services that we
can deliver on Prem and then remote and
we definitely saw the scale of this
requiring and on a remote component yeah
and actually that riffing on that a
little bit one of the other things we
liked about Pythian was they they were
very accountable there were multiple a
lot of check points where if we felt it
wasn't working we could just stop
working with them and do it ourselves
and that type of confident accountable
commitment was enormous ly appealing to
us okay so how was the planning side
probably three years ago you would see a
lot of people talking about my my cloud
migration methodology and yes that's
important yes we have a methodology it's
just not as important as it was back
then now it really comes down to you
really need to leverage native
components if you're gonna have a
successful migration so you know what is
the knowledge on the native side the
other one is the execution side you're
talking 17,000 machine
so how are you gonna execute that so
planning becomes more than just meetings
it becomes a mix of what are the human
and software mixes you're gonna bring in
to actually execute that in the timeline
this actually we'll get to this a little
bit later but we broke all of the
machines down into easy medium hard very
hard and the easy ones represented the
bulk of the machines but we'll dive into
this a little bit more later so what is
the double bubble this is the thing that
your CEO and CFO will hate so the idea
is great I'm gonna migrate to the cloud
and I will immediately start spending
less money that is not what is going to
happen let's say you're a 10 or it you
know a hundred on this graph you're
gonna go from spending that and then
you're gonna ramp up your destination
debt at data center and resources and
you're gonna spend more and then you're
gonna ramp up your migration partner and
you're gonna spend more so you'll get
from n to you know 1.5 N or 2n and so
the in on this graph the area that is
above the 100 that's the double bubble
and if you don't plan for it it will
bite you in the butt and you're gonna
have a bad time it might seem a little
counterintuitive to also add the
migration partner on there like oh
that's more expensive if you don't do
that and we have done this without
migration partners before with other
companies it just takes longer and you
end up spending more on the double
bubble that migration partner is a
definitely a worthwhile investment yeah
we experienced this in our personal
lives like if you move houses you have
an overlap where you own two houses and
you're probably paying a moving company
in the middle also and I've never heard
it referred to as the double bubble but
it is hopefully a phrase that catches on
one of the themes we're gonna get into
is just if you're gonna take on a
migration of this size it has to be not
just sponsored or supported by the sea
level it needs to be owned by the sea
level because this bubble is meaningful
amounts of money I mean this graph is
not to scale right but it's a meaningful
amount of money and if there is delays
in the process then you want sea level
support for it that the destination is
worth the double bubble and stay stay
the course if it's just owned in IT for
example then you can have sea level
concern anxiety a lot of
awkward discussions that that it's gonna
be make it more difficult to get through
the double bubble yeah
for us the double bubble was about six
months and about three million dollars
so not not a small amount of money one
thought on how you shortness I already
mentioned using a migration partner I
also recommend you know when you look if
you've got multiple data centers you're
migrating you can either say okay here
they all are and I'm gonna take all the
machines of this type and move them up
and then this type and move them up etc
I strongly recommend instead saying I'm
gonna take this data center the whole
thing I'm gonna move everything up that
I can and everything that can't move
will move it to our consolidation data
center and then turn it off you can
immediately turn off the electricity you
can not renew your lease you can look at
can I sub these shrink my footprint
there and you can start to release the
team or the portions of the team that
you don't need anymore so you can start
chunking cost out which for us with ten
data centers that was that was impactful
okay so we talked about humans and and
software so we did use a an automation
migration service for this and a POC so
the humans are important to figure out
the first ones and software's great at
taking once it's figured out let's
software run it again and again and
again this is a bit of a busy slide we
broke it out into a bunch of slide so
you can understand what it is but
basically humans proved out each system
type and that was categorized and then
an inventory was executed against so the
inventory it actually wasn't that
shocking a piece of technology I think
it was just Google sheets that we that
we wrote these systems into some of them
were super easy to inventory and then
through software others were very hard
and I think you're gonna get into that
later Jamie about that and so that was
all written in inventory that was the
execution plan then the automation
service looked at that inventory pulled
server names from it a automation agent
was attempted to be installed on the on
premise machine if that was successful
then you kept going if not it was put in
the deal with later bucket basically the
human attendant bucket the agent would
then replicate that
that OS instance would take it to GCSE
Google Cloud storage
once that was verified as a as a real
image it was then take taken in and
Sanchi ated in GCE Google compute engine
as a VM and that would be then flagged
into the inventory as okay and then not
OK's were then sent for human
involvement later and that's really how
and it was an iterative process because
new inventory would show up as as the
process was executing engineers had to
handle the exception so the obvious
question that everyone asks is what was
your success rate and it's kind of as
you would think for the for the systems
that were quite well understood recent
versions of Windows recent versions of
Linux we had about a 90 percent success
rate and then the ones that were older
versions of those had about an eighty
six eighty percent failure rate so you
can imagine where your humans were
spending their time was all on the
exceptions and the sort of wrote Windows
and wrote Linux boxes were very much
handled through the migration process so
that's that's how you get that many
machines moved in well call it six
months yeah so some challenges we
encountered during the migration if you
boil it down it's it's the middle one
there was just too much crap there we
had a business that was formed by
multiple acquisitions and ball toms and
so we had more than 50 flavors of OS you
know all sorts of different varieties of
Linux and Windows but also AIX 8 bucks
solaris so we said all right everything
that's on Windows upgrade to a recent
version that will be supported and keep
you know only one or two versions and be
disciplined about that do the same thing
with Linux and then for all of your
other flavors of operating system do you
really really need it like really really
can you shut that down can you move that
load on to something else and in some
cases we could can you refactor but in
in the cases where you couldn't you know
fine keep that keep it on bare metal
install
in one data center so we went from
50-plus flavors down to about ten so we
had you know 80% reduction there and
then on the too much crap side there's a
mindset with physical data centers where
I have I bought all this stuff if I'm
not using it I'm kind of wasting the
resource that I paid for so I might as
well use it
and if there isn't real discipline on
the team then you can fill that up and
then the team that's managing the data
center says oh my God we're at 94 95
percent utilization we've should maybe
buy some more hardware so then you buy
more and then you use that etc so the
way we handled this was we did a
physical inventory which takes actually
longer than than we expected it to and
then we had departments have to claim
each machine and and explain why it
needed to be migrated and then
everything that didn't get claimed we
turned off and then inevitably you know
hands were raised I do actually need
that and here's why and that's fine
we're not trying to be jerks about it it
was more just hey let's not migrate
anything that isn't truly needed we cut
our migration effort by about 50% just
doing this which realistically this
exercise probably should have been an
annual one or more frequently than that
anyway but it have to cut our effort a
lot then tiny pipes you know I'm sure
all of you have lots of data we
certainly did and if you try and push
that over the pipe that is good for
day-to-day use it's going to take
forever strong recommendation is to use
the Google transfer appliance if that
works for you so I think that's in North
America and I think it's I think it's in
beta in Europe that's where we used it
in North America and we used it in
Europe for those of you who aren't
familiar with what that is it's a big
box that has a bunch of storage on it it
shows up at your data center you load
your data in ship it back to Google and
then they they load it in India where
that wasn't available we used a TCP
partner called I'm gonna mispronounce
that but I think it's sippy say for you
yeah and that cut our migration time I
increase the pipe size and cut our
migration time from about seven months
down to six weeks
yeah sorry just if I get out onto the
tiny pipes picture this from our teams
we see this as being a chronic problem
in a lot of migrations is when you
you're moving that many VMs think about
route C drives how much data that is
that you're gonna be moving certainly
not going to be the bandwidth you used
on a daily basis right but it's also
it's not just the bandwidth it's the
resiliency of that network like one of
the things we ran into in this was a was
a network a network equipment component
failure which it failed we tried to
troubleshoot it at some point you just
have to give up on troubleshooting and
you have to we just put in a new one we
replaced it and I'm sure we've you ever
figured out what the problem of it was
but we would have found that if we had
run like a two-day hammer test to battle
test the network and that's I think
sometimes there's easy to do the
calculations on the bandwidth that
you've set up from a provider but do you
have you know all the failure points of
a network and making sure that you have
run a multi-day test against that on the
networking side also yes the the data
transfer appliance does work very well
and we recommend using that from it is
kind of networking lock down the
components lock down security as much as
you can before you move and then also
don't give more internet access than you
had on Prem even though cloud might tend
to make you do that if you if you have a
limited amount of internet access
perhaps none don't change that you know
as you move over is sort of another
networking tip yeah totally agree to
slow neat robots so we had thousands of
machines we needed to migrate if we had
done this by hand as a friend of mine
says lovingly handcrafted it would have
taken ages and and there definitely
would have been human error and then the
knock-on effects would have been
unpredictable and not good so for a
migration of any scale you've got to
invest in automation and then dog ate my
password this was a problem with the
inventory
and with the with the automation we were
turning around situation and bleeding
money and we couldn't afford to wait and
so by the time we actually started the
data center migration a lot of the team
that had been managing some of those
machines were gone so I think we had
like 20% of our machines we didn't have
the passwords for so we had to send
people into the data centers to reset
those and it wasn't like we identified
all of them at once and did it in batch
it was kind of we discovered it and sent
someone in and then discovered it and
sent someone in so recommendation would
be make sure that you have the passwords
upfront which seems like a no-brainer
but it can bite you in the bud so now
I'm I'm in GCP now what so it can be a
bit of a runaway roller coaster if
you're not careful you've got a team
that's used to hey there's this resource
and there's almost no incremental cost
if I spin up more stuff in that - now
everything you spin up cost you money
and you can earn a lot of cash very very
quickly if you're not careful so the
first recommendation here is like you
said lock it down so lock down the
internet access but in terms of
provisioning new resources
nobody gets rights to do this anymore
its centralized to your SAS ops team
have a request system you know the forum
or whatever where people say I want this
this is how much resource I want this is
the project it's for this is the layer
of the application it's for this is my
budget this is how long I need it for
and yeah it's you know it's a pain in
the butt and they'll be some pushback
initially but then the team gets on
board with it and and they're fine
if you don't do this you're gonna have a
bad time I promise you and this then
ties into labeling all of the resources
and then you can monitor and keep track
of are you are you staying above or
below your your budget target as far as
reduce and simplify we had had four
different support ticket tracking
systems we had eight different source
control systems we had a hundred and
twenty plus RDP boxes and kind of the
list goes on right so we said okay let's
we're gonna adopt one ticket tracking
system and we're going to move
eight down to one source control system
and we're gonna go from 120 RDP servers
down to four etc etc right take that
approach everywhere you can to converge
onto one system for a given function and
to make more efficient use of the
resources on those you know you had the
easy through most difficult systems and
you're at the bottom one of the
casualties was the hp-ux yeah boxes I'm
assuming someone made a compelling case
that those had to stay and had to move
how did you how did you deal with that I
don't remember exactly what they were
being used for but it was I think it was
one of the source control systems and so
we turned him off so that that took care
of that so just back to the sea level
yeah I need to get to a destination that
has a good cost footprint and and
driving that through yeah yeah so once
you've done your consolidation set
extreme goals as I mentioned earlier
that the team that had been there when
we got involved their approach was well
we can get you know 10 20 30 percent
improvement if you set extreme goals it
forces people to be creative they have
to reevaluate their assumptions and say
god if I'm gonna get 90% how am I even
gonna do that maybe we don't need this
system maybe we can consolidate as
opposed to a I will keep everything but
can we just be a little more efficient
so set the goal posts out there and this
is another place that you need that
that's C suite buy-in because if you
don't have that and you said extreme
goals someone's gonna go screaming you
know up the flagpole and then you'll get
pushed back so how do you optimize first
one is easy right take advantage of the
the GCP pricing hooks so use sustained
use discounts committed volume sorry
committed committed use discounts if you
don't need something to be outside of
the US keep your load in the u.s. it's
forget the best pricing that way those
are the easy ones monitor everything so
everything has to be tagged monitor CPU
memory disk utilization I used to work
at
like 15 years ago and Michael Dell's big
thing is if you can is it if you can
measure it you can improve it so make
sure you are measuring everything and
that way you can track you know how much
have I spent on this is what's my
velocity am I gonna go above or below my
budget for the quarter and it's okay you
know if you're tracking you go above it
maybe you need to but you can catch it
soon enough that you can adjust course
and dial back other stuff or maybe
you're going over budget in a bad way
you can catch that fast and then being
ruthlessly efficient so reap platform
Windows to Linux which is a hassle but
do it you'll save money delete on attach
disks every day
delete snapshots and and images as soon
as they're not needed if you don't need
solid-state don't use it and there's
valid reasons to use solid-state so I'm
not saying don't use it but if you don't
need it don't use it it costs more and
then use make use of the recommendations
that GCP gives you they'll say hey you
know this machine is only running at 20%
CPU utilization maybe you should shrink
it use those don't rely exclusively on
that you're gonna want to do your own
analysis but definitely make use of that
automate so we've talked about
automation during migration automation
afterwards is also important we now Auto
terminate anything that isn't labeled
initially we weren't enforcing the
labeling so when we put this policy in
we gave people a heads up and were like
okay after this point things will be
terminated and then we would give them
you know for the first two or three
cycles we said hey these resources
aren't labeled we're gonna turn them off
tomorrow now we don't even wait it just
if it's not labeled properly it gets
killed
also look for kind of standard patterns
of use so you can probably turn the
machines off at night that your
engineers are using and on the weekend
it's not that they can't turn them back
on if they need to work late at night or
over the weekend but turn that stuff off
if it's not needed look for other
patterns like if you're testing team
only needs the testing environment and
the first and third week of the month
great turn that environment off the rest
of the time and then use auto scaling
marlee that can be helpful - on the
second one go GCP native so there's two
mindsets here one mindset is i really
want to stay agnostic right i don't want
to get fully committed to one cloud
provider because then i'm locked in and
I lose pricing pressure that's not the
direction we went because if you do that
then you can't take advantage of all the
great things that the cloud provider
brings to the table for us with TCP
spanner is phenomenal right it's a it's
a game changer for us and we're not
we're not doing like a generic it's a
database thing we're doing
it's spanner and we're using all the
hooks that we can in it we're also going
full-bore on on gke on prem which is now
called anthos the name hasn't stuck in
my head yet but we're going full-bore on
that as well so we recommend going and
embracing that the GCP is your provider
and really go full bore on what they
bring to the table they invest a ton of
money and the stuff and it's it's worth
using yeah we could ask this quite often
is how do i architect my application so
that i can quickly move from one cloud
to the other this was actually the same
discussion we had back on the date in
the database space what how can i build
an application for this database but
move it to any other our advice then is
the same as it is now on on clout which
is if you architect your application
properly and leverage native native
capabilities of the cloud you will be
better off than trying to do some homage
homogeneous I'm sorry heterogeneous shim
layer that you can rapidly move from
cloud to cloud you never get there you
couldn't do it on database I don't think
you'll do it on you know on cloud so if
you architect your apps properly then
you will spend less if you decide to
move then trying to bet on the future of
a move I can commit to the platform that
your that your engineering on and and
leverage the native components yeah and
this last last point papers please so
make sure that you're collecting the
certificates as you decommission
hardware you may get audited and
having that paperwork is is helpful we
did and it was helpful so how did we do
so we started at 15 million a year we
are currently at 4 million a year after
six months so we've saved 11 million
already which even factoring in the
three million doublebubble it's it's
more than paid for itself and we're
gonna get to 1.5 million by next quarter
so that 90 percent target we we are
going to hit it and that's all in right
that's including our GCP spend as well
and the team that's dedicated to it and
if you look at all the different other
metrics that I mentioned at the
beginning you know how many data centers
square footage electricity etcetera
Tedder we've got between eighty and a
hundred percent on everyone but the big
big metric for us is cash out the door
and this has been enormously successful
from that standpoint and these ten data
centers that was sort of due to the the
cereal acquiring nature of the business
that's how you got ten data centers
that's how you had so many footprints so
many engineers yeah yeah we had I mean
we ended up with I think we had three
data centers just in Germany which we
really didn't need and we had two in
India we had one in Rio and we had one
in Kansas City and like it was just all
in Toronto it was all over the place and
the ones in India were customer driven
but the other ones was just came with
the acquisitions so takeaways pick your
partners carefully clearly we we like
GCP and and Pythian plan for the double
bubble it's gonna happen and if you if
you aren't planning for it it will bite
you in the butt and you'll have a bad
time Doucette extreme goals it it forces
the team to get creative and initially
there's a little bit of oh my god what
the hell are you thinking but it works
out you know and then own it at the sea
level if you want results like this yeah
I'll just add color to the governed lift
and shift because I know that there is
lift and shift has
sort of can have a bad connotation with
it that can mean your CFO is not happy
at the end of it this was what was
called a governed lift and shift so a
lot of housecleaning done beforehand
again I owned it the sea level and then
house then you could argue I think Jamie
you did earlier saying you could do this
you could have done this on Prem but
what we see is just people don't there's
no big there's no big rip in the fabric
that causes you to actually well first
get the money to do it
yeah and secondly paint a destination
that's really compelling so this is much
like all digital transformation now
really means cloud and it's because you
can you have the the mandate to go
through this so clean it up I mean you
didn't talk about it on the previous
slide but going from seven sorry fifty
OS instance types to support down to
seven is huge yeah and then that makes
it makes a massive difference the other
piece and I call this the surprise
invoice that drive CFOs crazy you guys
were very frugal with who you gave
rights to actually go spin up more
assets yep
that's credit because even if you land
in your destination and and the the
price is really good for February if it
blows up in March and April then then
you haven't really achieved anything
so really figure out who needs the
rights to set up those clusters who
needs those and only give them out to
people who are accountable to the
business for that increased spend yep
and we've we did that right here because
we've made that mistake on other other
deals so it was a painfully learned
lesson and then the last point on here
monitor everything do do be ruthless and
I can't stress enough the default
configuration will just be to monitor
CPU but you really want to monitor
memory and disk utilization as well and
you want to have everything labeled so
that you can quickly dive in and say
okay who's you know I'm spending two
thousand more per day than I was
expecting
where did that come from okay George
what's going on why you know why you
suddenly spent any more
[Music]